MATERIAL THAT WAS WITHHELD, NOW
WE’VE DISCOVERED HE WENT TO JAIL
FOR NOTHING.
LET’S REMEMBER THAT THE JURY
FOREPERSON IN ROGER STONE’S CASE
HAD A POLITICAL BIAS.
SHE EXPRESSED PUBLICLY AGAINST
HIM, TWEETING ABOUT HER HATRED
FOR TRUMP SUPPORTER’S, DRUM, AND
ROGER STONE.
THIS WAS BEFORE THE TRIAL AND
NOW WE KNOW PREMEDITATED FRAUD
BY THE FISA COURT WAS EVEN WORSE
THAN WE HAD BEEN TELLING YOU.
THEY KNEW ALL ALONG IT WAS
RUSSIAN INFORMATION THAT WAS FED
TO CHRISTOPHER STEELE FROM
RUSSIA KNOWING IT WAS BEING PAID
FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON.
MEANWHILE, GENERAL FLYNN’S
ATTORNEY SIDNEY POWELL NOW
BELIEVES THAT NEW EVIDENCE
PROVES WHAT LIEUTENANT GENERAL
MICHAEL FLYNN WAS SET UP AND
FRAMED BY CORRUPT AGENTS WHO
WITHHELD EXCULPATORY MATERIAL.
NOW ASKING FOR THIS CASE TO BE
THROWN OUT BASED ON MISCONDUCT.
HERE WITH MORE, THE COAUTHOR OF
THE "CONVICTION MACHINE,
STANDING UP TO PROSECUTORIAL
ABUSE."
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR SIDNEY
POWELL.
WE SAW WITH PAPADOPOULOS AND
ROGER STONE, THIS IS A
MISCARRIAGE OF JUSTICE.
YOU’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
MATERIAL AND EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE.
NOW WE ARE TOLD WE ARE ON THE
VERGE OF BROOD >> RELEASE OF
MORE DOCUMENTS THAT WILL SHOW
GENERAL FLYNN WAS INNOCENT AND
WAS COMPLETELY SET UP AND FRAMED
BY THE UPPER ECHELON OF THE FBI.
THAT SMALL GROUP OF THE HIGHEST
RANKING MEMBERS OF THE FBI THAT
DELIBERATELY SET UP THAT FIRM
AUGUST 15TH 2016 ON TO CATCH
GENERAL FLYNN IN SOMETHING AND
EITHER PROSECUTE HIM OR GET HIM
FIRED.
THAT’S WHAT WE HAVE ALLEGED FOR
SO LONG AND IT’S PROVING TRUE
WITH EVERY NEW DOCUMENT
DISCLOSED.
>> Sean: SO YOU HAVE THE JURY
FOREPERSON WHO HAS A DIRECT
BIAS, I THOUGHT WE HAD A RIGHT
TO AN IMPARTIAL JURY, I MUST
HAVE DELUDED MYSELF.
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE WITHHELD IN
HIS CASE, LOOKS LIKE
GENERAL FLYNN’S CASE, LOOKS LIKE
ALL OF IT, THEY KNEW ALL ALONG
IT WAS RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
EVERYWHERE.
CAN WE EXPECT OR READ INTO THE
HIRING OF MORE STAFF AND
PROSECUTORS BY A SIGN THAT
THINGS ARE RATCHETING UP FOR
JUSTICE?
>> IT CERTAINLY LOOKS LIKE HE’S
ON THE RIGHT TRACK AND THE
DISCLOSURE OF THESE DOCUMENTS ON
THE ADVICE THAT MORE ARE TO COME
IS GOING TO HELP FROM ALL
ANGLES.
IT’S A FIRST STEP TOWARDS
RESTORING INCREDIBLY CREDIBILITY
THIS INFORMATION EXPOSED.
THE U.S. ATTORNEY JOYCE LYNN
VALENTINE ASSIGNED TO THE CASE
HAS ADVISED THAT SINCE FRIDAY
THAT THEY’RE WORKING TO
UNREDACTED CERTAIN PARTS OF THE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE FILED UNDER
SEAL ON FRIDAY SO THAT THEY CAN
BE DISCLOSED PUBLICLY EITHER
TOMORROW OR WEDNESDAY.
CAN’T HAPPEN SOON ENOUGH FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
>> Sean: HE IS SCHEDULED JAIL
THURSDAY.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
I WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE NOT.
I WOULD THINK AT THE VERY LEAST
A COURT WOULD GRANT HIM A STAY
PENDING HIS APPEAL BECAUSE THERE
ARE SERIOUS ISSUES IN HIS
APPEAL.
>> Sean: MY SOURCES ARE
TELLING ME TONIGHT THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS SEEN A LOT
OF THIS AND WHAT I’M TOLD IS IT
WAS BREATHTAKING, REVELATIONS,
SO PLEASE KEEP US UP TO SPEED.
THAT MAN SERVED HIS COUNTRY FOR
33 YEARS.
IS THIS HOW WE TREAT PEOPLE THAT
SERVE THEIR COUNTRY?
>> HE IS ABSOLUTELY INNOCENT.
HIS PLEA WAS COERCED BY LACK OF
INFORMATION AND THREAT TO INVITE
HIS SOUND THAT SHOWS ON THE